today I'm going to show you the top
three ways to create more happiness part
one the first way to create more
happiness is by fixing the ratio Studies
have found that about 80 percent of the
thoughts that we have on a day-to-day
basis are negative this is bad because
every time you have a negative thought
it comes with a negative feeling on the
other hand when you have a positive
thought like people love me what does
that do well it makes you feel good
right these type of thoughts do the
opposite they create happiness which is
why if you want to be happy you need to
fix the ratio of the amount of bad
thoughts you have every day to the
amount of good thoughts you have every
day the next way we can create more
happiness in our lives is by building
and maintaining social bonds see almost
all human beings have a built-in need
for social bonds it's in our DNA you
actually have to have them or else your
brain will shrink and there's a pretty
good chance that you'll develop some
form of mental illness when you have
conversations with people it's a form of
play you can exchange information you
can solve problems together these
activities create happiness within us
follow us for more helpful tips